hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on four again we got
some more year for info to talk about
today this is gonna be about the patch
notes the battle pass and some other
stuff that happened a little bit later
in the stream so kind of like the second
half or part two if you will so as
always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes they here
updates the pageant's and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update that if we stay subscribe to the
channel and with that you don't know
what's going on let's get into today's
video so for some patch note goodness
we're gonna be going over a few nerfs
and some buffs depending on what way you
think of them
so first up like I said is the patch
notes law bringers going to be getting
nerfed he has some brutal parry punishes
so he's going to be definitely affected
by this upcoming nerf gladiator will
also be receiving two nerfs they're
going to be increasing the revenge gain
that the opponent gets from toe stab I
believe the original was ten and now
it's thirty and they also decrease the
damage to haymaker which was ten and
it's now five euro got a nerf to the
damage I believe the stamina damage on
the yo tuned surge farewell gift and
grudge so pretty much all video two
moves and stamina bashes and then for
his second error and for his tier two
feet huh Mars favor you're gonna be
getting left shield staggers also occur
a little bit later and then suffer some
throws and some side heavy finishers so
awesome cool [ __ ] with that heat so
carry nerf is gonna be decreasing the
opener heavy by just a tad bit and then
now her throws throw just a little bit
further now see on d4 his own attack now
has a costing of way less stamina for
all different variations and now the
tiger Dodge has more availability when
you can delay the move I believe on the
stream it's at a hundred of 300
milliseconds and now that is 100 to 400
milliseconds meaning you have a little
bit more time to delay the move warlords
top light opener is now faster with the
throw duration being just a little bit
longer they increase some forward
momentum with the Ken saying nature's
wrath the gladiator dodge forward light
the Shaolin Lotus leap the black prior
10 abyss thrust and conquers open light
attacks infinite light attacks in the
charged heavy straightforward
strafe so any of those characters that
use are gonna be able to close the
distance a bit while you're still doing
moves I know I had a definite a little
bit of an issue especially playing as
gladiator on top of that for shinobi
Highlander and Concord they're charged
heavy openers are not going
to have a little bit of a time cancel
it's gonna be a little bit longer so
that's going to weaken their parry
option select that these three
characters use so if you definitely use
parry option selection for this kind of
thing definitely keep that in mind it's
not going to be a detrimental nerf and
they're not gonna go down to F tier but
it is still nerf nonetheless and then
they also improved a little bit of the
input comfort for the parry follow-ups
like a mirror raid for Nisha and the
skilled slash for berserkers are pretty
nice there's also going to be new ranked
rewards if you're into that kind of
thing I haven't played a ranked in
almost probably an entire year so it's
been a very long time but now there's
going to be rewards for I believe they
call that master so I believe you hit
the master rank and Grand Master you'll
be getting this there is no confirmation
yet on if there's going to be something
specific for only Grand Master's but at
least there's finally something for the
higher tier players to use and I'm
assuming this would change throughout
the season so you can only get this
through year four season one and then
year for season two coming you know
three months from now will have a
different effect or ornament or whatever
it happens lastly we're gonna be talking
about the Battle pass and as you can see
the background of the game is going to
be changing personally this is already
one of my favorite looking backgrounds
of so far out of all the background
changes we've had and underneath your
rep your scavenger crates and your steel
is going to be a little bar and it's
going to show your progression on the
battle pass if you're familiar with how
battle passes work then you already kind
of understand the process but to keep
this in mind if for any newer people
that don't understand this there's going
to be a free pass any premium pass the
premium pass is going to be coming with
a lot of the cooler content whereas the
free pass we'll have some stuff but it
won't be as cool as the para does the
premium pass and no matter what you're
still going to be earning XP towards the
past because you already have the free
one but let's say you get to you know
level 10 level 20 in you want to
actually end up buying the premium pass
as soon as you buy the premium pass
anything that you've unlocked up to that
point it will be automatically gifted to
you so if you're like tier 90 and then
you buy the pass you'll get everything
from tier once it's here 90 you don't go
all the way back to 1 because you bought
it so usually what I kind of do for
games that have this thing is I grind it
as much as I want and if I'm satisfied
with the rewards that I've gotten up to
this point then I'll buy the pass if not
then I'll keep the free pass if grinding
is not your thing and you're lazy like
your boy you could buy tiers using steel
2500 steel
gonna be one tier five tiers will be ten
thousand and twenty tiers will be twenty
five thousand the sequ waiting - roughly
I believe a little bit over 100,000
steel I believe the correct is 1020 err
I believe the correct number is 125,000
steel which is a little bit over $100
which is very very obvious for most
games that have battle passes I think
this is pretty standard so yeah if you
want to buy the entire battle pass
through the tiers you could do that if
you want to grind you can also do that
as well when the tier and the battle
pass stuff comes out I will definitely
be having a video how to grind the
battle past the most so you don't have
to waste your steel on these tiers but I
have to get to the battle pass and it
actually has to release so we'll have to
wait on that video for now so as you're
seeing on screen you're seeing a few
other things that they're mentioning so
for example I myself am NOT a warden
main so when i unlock the wyvern Dale
Lord weapon set for warden
I am lower than rep 1 so I'll be getting
the grey variation but if your rep 10
and up and stuff you're gonna be getting
the teal version it's going to be
whatever tier that you're or rep it's
going to be whatever rep that your hero
is at and of course with the trans
mugging and the changed look that really
doesn't matter so once if you do wrap up
warden in the future then you can of
course equipped that for the legendary
status but you will not be getting
legendary weapons out the gate for the
character it's for whatever rep that the
character you get the weapon for it'll
be so like I said for example I'm a rep
Cyril with warden so when I do unlock
this mine will be gray the yours might
be different depending on our reps
you're also gonna be seeing some stuff
at the bottom that have numbers with a
faction so for example Indy tier 1 they
didn't actually show this but it looks
like some type of emo it's maybe some
other type of effect or whatever it is
for 26 that means it's going to be for
all the characters for example then we
get to tier 4 and we have the tail of
wyvern Dale execution effect now this is
an effect for all of the Nights and
that's why it says the number 7 there
are seven characters within the Nights
faction so that is strictly for the
Nights I'm assuming this effect will
also be shown somewhere in the future of
the battle pass for the other types of
factions but they only showed us the
first five at the moment so yeah there's
no confirmation on when they're actually
going to show us the all 100 tiers of
the battle past there is going to be a
dev stream next week so that could be
the time that they show it but maybe
they won't because you know the new
season is releasing and maybe there's
something different going on so we'll
have to see what happens all throughout
next week and what the
dealio what that is but finally
something that we haven't talked about
in a very very long time is the emote
contest months ago where they were doing
an email contest people from the
community could send in their emotes and
then we could have the chance of having
one of those emotes in-game if it got
featured and they are finally working on
the animations and they are actually
going to release them soon and here is
an example of one of the emotes that
you're seeing on screen this is one of
the people's featured ones and then this
is what it'll look like in game it looks
absolutely fantastic I cannot wait I was
warning when they were gonna be talking
about this and they kept us a little
hush-hush for months thankfully we
finally have confirmation that that is
still a thing that they're doing and
then lastly if you're in the mood to
toss a coin dear which your kind of
thing the coin toss emote is gonna be
half off on the sale so definitely go
pick that up if you want to do that it's
only gonna be available for this
upcoming week so if you get it you have
to get it before the new seasons last
year starts or it won't be discounted
anymore but yeah with that guys like the
B if you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new hopefully you enjoyed today's video
a lot of stuff we're gonna be talking
about a lot of stuff coming next week
huge info I'm super excited for year for
let me know if you guys think about this
stuff in the comments below I like to be
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
and with that guys take care I love you
all peace out
[Music]
you